woke is a reference to when someone
adheres to the social Orthodoxy of the
dominant institutions and it's a
morphous sometimes it's woke sometime
like sometimes it's see I woke in the
esoteric sense sometimes it's
postmodernist critical race theory
gender ideology sometimes it's
absolutely not and Everyone Falls in
line the the best way to understand this
is how the left uses a m and Bailey
tactic if the left was truly if woke
truly was postmodernism there would be
You Know M and Bailey they'd quite
literally say here's our argument have a
nice day but they don't they change
their argument to a civil libertarian
argument when threatened showing there
is no actual ideology here it is simply
just we are a group that is in line with
each other we look for others who are
wearing the same color clothing and so
long as we do that and we're up to dat
on the on the latest fashion we are
aligned that's what woke is